yo re Thea what's happening man
divergent colognian from Port Douglas
Australia modulation for re well this is
a Maori could you please elaborate on
that salvia trip he had back in the day
back with the old red band I believe you
said it felt like you were living
underwater for four months to two years
there's a bit elaborate on that every
pretty pretty cool is this sounds pretty
interesting
here's a problem dicey question yeah I
did a lot word on that's why he's
getting that and when it took like five
full minutes and he's getting that and
he's pretty much asked his question like
I want to hear you talk that's a dumb
question bro we got another if we just
want to move on or do you want to get
into it I mean I took a heavy salvia
truck it's been alone how much is that
like a couple hours so we took a bond
what does it come in a little pal KITT
how pouch you can get him at circus of
books that on a Santa mom you really
cinema yeah it wasn't illegal they might
have made it legal since then but one of
those under the radar drugs and you
process it 20 times 40 times 60 times
even 80 times the more processor was the
higher the higher potency was read band
was into it and yeah I think I'd done it
once before it makes you like lose your
balance who start seeing stuff from like
childhood and the color yellow a lot oh
yeah
anyway so we were doing it on a podcast
and I took a big hit at up out of a bomb
but I wasn't used to like smoking like a
lot of people go like you know when you
see a bong it'll clear at all and yeah I
cough I could do half a bong here then I
got to do the rest of the bong hit the
weed so I did as much as I could and I
was like start coughing but they were
like that wasn't a full [ __ ] hit but
it got me to where I was like like right
on the line it was sugar so I was
already like got a head start on it like
you know do a real hit and I was like ah
I was like about to trip out and then I
did this massive which would have been
plenty
the first time but I did that in
conjunction with the other hit and you
ain't deep I was gone oh yeah I mean I
was not there any more [ __ ] couple of
orphans driving your brain yeah I guess
I was laying there I don't know how long
but like so then I started living in
this like under water in his lake behind
my child at home I was just there I had
a life I friends I had a job I had this
woman I had a relationship with oh wow
and it was like it went on and so I said
I
I don't remember exactly but it's I
would say somewhere between six months
and two years
mm-hmm I was down there you know and you
live in a sports teams we're doing well
all underwater you know in this
underwater land we're all like sea
horses and [ __ ] came in one day you know
breathe in water fine one day I'm
swimming up around and I just see right
out of the water right at the edge of
the water probably closes we're sitting
right now that's why I was just act out
and I say the edge olara dude a human
dude oh yeah what and it was Sam Tripoli
Wow and I just swim up to him I could
see him being somewhere I like there
yeah I mean he was there in the room
with me so but that's I was like
starting to come back eight nine ten
minutes later and I was like what the
[ __ ] is that
and then I like kind of popped up but it
was Sam but I wasn't all the way back
yet they gave me some water and I was
had to spin it up because I was like no
you breathe water you know that's
amniotic bright you got all amniotic
yeah and then I was like another 15
minutes so I was like back again I was
like I was like wait I'm not here it's
kind of like Inception you know Ellie in
her back way no no oh oh yeah oh yeah
this is this is life yeah but I thought
I had a new life I thought she was out
there that was it good that was a good
trip it looks shitty look like if you
see the video because we haven't taped
it it looked pretty awful but it wasn't
awful man I'm a crybaby the McRib is
back son
that's what it sounds like he's a good
tiger I do that again it's a dirty drug
is it yeah it's a coke is a dirty drug
yeah mushrooms and acid are not dirty
you know MDMA is I don't know what about
that DMT have you done it it wants I
didn't quite get there you don't never
done it I'm gonna do it again I did it I
was in my backyard I'm you know I have
that fact oh yeah I've been out there
smoking cigarettes before yeah that's
great
that's the best part of my apartment
yeah it's nice dude I saw a couple times
when I got locked out and go over that
garden that's called buildings down I'd
have jumped the fence into that garden
go through the garden and then jump
through the back areas of the other
between that building between you and
that garden area to get to you luckily
left the door unlocked
yes Wow cuz it seems fine to leave it
unlock it salt fence like who would go
there the [ __ ] bridge people next
door
no why did you get that many times I was
crazy
middle of the night [ __ ] three I mean
somebody black what the [ __ ] are you
doing call the cops
never missed a jump wow that's great
this yeah [ __ ] it could not hold on
those keys man yeah so I was lying that
next this girl we smoke some DMT hmm she
was gone I was like going and then I was
laying there in that tree saw this uh
this caterpillar oh yeah this hexagon
like like like things made up of a
caterpillar come down to the tree and I
was just looking at it and he looked at
me for a while and I looked back at him
and then he just goes no and then just
like caterpillars back up the tree and I
was like I was out of it I was like what
yeah I looked at the girl and she was
like I just died and came back to jus
and I was like no I don't think I got
invited she's like oh you missed out Wow
yeah he said no wasn't ready I guess wow
yeah I got to do it again I have some
mother nature came looking for you
anywhere I'm ready for now so you know
in fact maybe maybe in uh in Phoenix or
uh in Phoenix and Tempe and Miami and
West Palm maybe maybe a toughy in
Phoenix maybe but maybe a fan will give
me something I can do something with
Adriene smoke some [ __ ] DMT who's a
junior lady no Adrian a pallucci opens
for me sometimes just a real dark comic
from New York oh yeah I met her before
yeah and uh I got her high in Austin
she's cool [ __ ] she is cool but
shouldn't get high much and she started
being convinced that I was gonna kill
her that's why I invited her out there
and she couldn't get it out of her head
and I saw instantly and I'm like oh I
already been through this with other
friends there's no way I can convince
you because of course I would really
kill him yeah so every time I was like
oh I took the wrong way the wrong way
where are we going I'm like agent I
could have killed you anywhere yeah I
don't need to go long waste all this gas
money kill you would have to out the
house well that's like Shane Moss was on
here he ate about a bunch of drugs right
he went you know he got all buzz all
cheering Moss goes for it yeah dude and
he uh and he hired a film crew to make a
documentary and then he thought the film
crew was stealing his life and secrets
so we started giving clues to the camera
that he would then watch later down the
road so that he would be able to know
what was really going on mini went to
the hospital Wow yeah we did mushrooms
every day for a month or do you try to
do mushrooms every day for a month but
then right when he started he apparently
somebody might even do some DMT and he
agreed to do it and it was just too much
at once he said holding himself with
this [ __ ] that wouldn't let it come out
of his pores yeah
something root and so uh then it just
like kept circling around in his body he
got caught up well that's the dark art
dude I saw him a month or two later and
Pink Floyd Roger Waters concert in in
like yeah he invited me and my lady and
was great it was a great concert but he
was like he hadn't taken anything for a
while but the way he was talking was
like that that you know that 30 minutes
to an hour after you come out of your
mushroom trip and you're still kind of
half there and half there he was talking
like that all the time but yeah he's
still there a little bit he's still a
bit of a loose stool if you ask me what
else do we have here for mr. re I did
that lime bit cut some DMT once mhm
not CMC sorry MDMA once and from one of
the store dealers at the time and I
remember like I hadn't taken I was like
where's ecstasy
that's what it was was just like hazard
in there and I was like in a Vegas
casino with Eddie Bravo and Rogan and
[ __ ] I'm starting to feel like oh [ __ ]
it might have been taken too much I
might OD I remember texting myself I got
these drugs from Sandy damn toe so if
somebody if I'd died if somebody found
my thing they were like jail for what he
did to me you know what's crazy as my
sister can't even read but what does it
have to do with us right now hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options watch one this one